>>> HBO'S THE LAST OF US IS A
HIT SO A VIDEO GAME CAN BECOME A
PRESTIGE DRAMA IN SPRING, HBO IS
DOING IT AGAIN WITH ANOTHER
ICONIC GAME.
>> IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS SINCE OUR
KINGDOM FELL.
THE ONLY THING WE HAVE LEFT,
HOPE.
>> I HAVE IMPORTANT CARGO I NEED
SMUGGLED TO RAINBOW ROAD.
PEOPLE SAY YOU USED TO DRIVE.
>> PEOPLE SAY A LOT OF THINGS.
>> YOU GOT A NAME?
>> IT'S A-ME, MARIO.
WHAT'S IN THE CARGO?
>> NOT WHAT.
WHO.
SHE'S A PRINCESS.
AT LEAST SHE WAS UNTIL HE TOOK
OVER.
>> WE'LL NEVER MAKE IT ON FOOT.
>> YOU WON'T HAVE TO.
>> LET'S A-GO.
>> FROM THE PRODUCERS OF THE
LAST OF US AND THE MASTER STORY
TELLERS BEHIND MARIO CARTS 1
THROUGH 8.
>> WHAT'S IT LIKE OUT HERE?
>> COMING OUT HERE ISN'T A GAME.
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT, WE
NEED ALL THE HELP WE CAN GET.
>> IT'S A-LUIGI TIME.
>> EVERYONE ON THIS ROAD WANTS
US DEAD.
>> WHAT IS THAT THING?
>> GOOMBA.
FUNGUS, WEARING SHOES FOR LEGS.
>> DRAMATIC HBO CHARACTERS.
>> I'M YOSHI.
I'M BISEXUAL.
>> NAME'S TOAD.
ALSO, I'M BISEXUAL.
>> HBO PICKED THE WRONG GAME TO
DO THIS WITH, RAVES VARIETY.
>> YEAH, THIS AIN'T IT, ADDS THE
NEW YORK TIMES.
>> YOU EAT THAT POISON?
>> IT MAKES ME FEEL BIG, OKAY?
I NEED TO FEEL BIG!
BECAUSE BOWSER'S OUT THERE.
AND HE'S THE MAIN BAD GUY.
♪♪
WE'RE OUT THERE IN OUR CARTS,
AND I NEED YOU TO TRUST ME.
I'LL GET YOU TO RAINBOW ROAD.
>> YOU CAN DO THIS!
>> NO.
IT'S RED.
>> WHAT IF WE CRASH?
>> A LITTLE GUY IN A CLOUD COMES
AND USES A FISHING POLE TO PUT
YOU BACK ON THE ROAD.
>> OH, OKAY.